this is where the delegates from Seven
African countries unveiled their
initiative to end the war in Ukraine 24
hours after meeting Ukraine's President
Vladimir zielinski and Kiev they
traveled to Saint Petersburg hoping to
convince President Vladimir Putin to
accept their peace plan
I want to emphasize once again we are
open to a constructive dialogue with
everyone who wants to establish peace on
the principles of justice and taking
into account the legitimate interests of
the parties the African delegation is
offering a detailed initiative starting
with de-escalation and ending with
negotiations we are here to communicate
a very clear message
that we would like this war
to be ended
we say so because this war is having a
negative impact
on the African continent
and indeed on many other countries
around the world
as a continent
we are being negatively affected in
terms of our economies
critics doubt whether the African
initiative can work saying it lacks both
the leverage and weight to push forward
a solution or the see it as a step in
the right direction
a real settlement on this issue can
begin only if there's a clear winner on
the ground or there's a deadlock only in
this case can we talk about a third path
and here the African initiative will
have a huge cumulative effect all the
previous initiatives the Chinese the
African and the Brazilian all can
together at a certain stage form the
basis of a settlement till then attempts
are expected to continue to bring both
sides to the table
it's very rare that African leaders
offer the mediation to solve such a
multi-layered global crisis but the war
in Ukraine is having a major impact on
their continent especially with the
threat exposing to Food Supplies and
some are optimistic that even if the
peace plan doesn't go through its ideas
could have a positive impact on the
conflict Ali Hashem al-jazeera Moscow
a new three-day ceasefire has begun in
Syria